[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
pour ce nouveau numéro de vip
aujourd'hui ne le consacrons à une
personnalité yvelinoise qui est
ornithologue et qui sort un livre qui
s'appelle ce que les oiseaux honte à
nous dire aux éditions fayard grégoire
loïs bonjour bonjour vous allez bien
très bien merci bon super c'est la
première fois que je fais une
visioconférence
voilà donc merci nous nous rejoindre
pour ce pour ce numéro vous êtes comment
vous définissez vous êtes en auto log et
vous travaillez au muséum d'histoire
naturelle voilà et vous diriger une
mission particulière exactement en fait
au muséum national d'histoire naturelle
je suis directeur adjoint d'une unité
qui valorise et qui promeut les sciences
participatives c'est à dire qu'en fait
on se repose propose et où se reposent
sur les observations des citoyens qui
veulent bien s'intéresser à la nature
ils ont dégagé des grands patrons
par exemple des grands patrons des
tendances si vous voulez rire
deux phénomènes naturels donc par
exemple l'indicateur oiseaux communs car
ddd productions les plus anciennes qu'on
a parce que ça remonte même à 1989 le
début de cette opération
38 dont le suivi temporel des oiseaux
communs oiseaux communs nous permet
d'évaluer au fur et à mesure des années
les variations de l'abondance des
espèces d'oiseaux sur le travail de
bénévole à l'école vous fait de faire le
travail par les autres c'est pas mal
comme principe est rajouté mois
effectivement c'est tout à fait le c'est
tout à fait le cas on fait faire le
travail par les hamas c'est que en ce
qui concerne par exemple la météo ou les
suivis de phénomène
d'épisodes de la raison de ravageurs
dans l'agriculture il ya beaucoup de la
puissance publique met beaucoup de
moyens mais finalement poursuivre la
biodiversité
hormis les espèces gibier d'une part il
n'y a pas grand chose à vous voulez des
drôles pour le petit quotidienne tous
les jours voilà c'est ça pour les
espèces qui sont pour la nature comme
dit ordinaire
je vous interromps parce que oiseaux
communs quels sont les oiseaux communs
il voit en cédric defrance si possible
alors les oiseaux communs c'est ce
qu'ils sont suffisamment à bout dans nos
statistiques pour être estimable donc en
l'occurrence c'est le merle noir la
fauvette à tête noire l'alouette des
champs qui risque de devenir moins
commune décline de manière assez
constante c'est le vrd d'europe le
pinson des arbres se tissaient tous les
oiseaux qu'on voit dans les parcs et
jardins mais aussi en ville aussi en vie
lui passant des bois le pinson des
arbres
beaucoup d'annoncés lui commandant tout
c'est sa petite ritournelle même dans
les allées de platanes au coeur des
villes il suffit de l'écouter
alors justement parce que vous parlez de
chants d'oiseaux il ya une chose qui m'a
assez frappé c'est lors de cette période
de confinement des caves une émission
avec un invité au téléphone c'était à on
entend les chants d'oiseaux ou ont enfin
on réentend les chants d'oiseaux
ce qui prouve quand même que c'est vital
pour nous humains et et que tout le
monde y est attaché à ces chants
d'oiseaux donc faudrait peut-être faire
un petit peu plus attention pour que ça
dure
déjà et qu'est ce qui vous a donné à
vous cet amour des oiseaux ce qui est
une histoire de transmission ou pas non
finalement il ya ces petites histoires
de transmission dans ma famille il y
avait un intérêt
je le curieux hésité pour pour la nature
mais pas une transmission de savoir donc
c'est curieux transmission de curiosité
acier moulé pour les à dire que je me
rappelle donc j'ai grandi mois aux
essarts-le-roi pas très très loin entre
la vallée de chevreuse et le massif de
rambouillet si vous voulez le long de la
nationale 10 et donc on avait des
hirondelles de cheminée l'hirondelle
avec la queue qui a de longs fils elle a
malheureusement voit cette population
diminue vraiment fortement et donc on
avait des hirondelles de cheminée qui
nichait dans le garage qui restait
ouvert en permanence et je me rappelle
de voir mon père moi j'étais gamin qui
sort des vieilles jumelles de famille
pas très efficace il faut bien le dire
et qui sort un bouquin espèce de groupe
aucun du type les animaux du monde voilà
un plus pas très pas très précis non
plus et qui essaie de voir ce que sont
ces espèces et qui passent des heures à
regarder ça donc effectivement pas
d'ornithologues dans ma famille
biologiste où ça s'est construit comme
ça c'est à dire que j'avais la chance
d'avoir un jardin des normes avec un
bois avec une marge très bien qu'est ce
que vous dites nous votre livre est ce
que vous ce qui vous réjouit c'est que
vous en revanche vous avez vraiment
transmis cette passion de l'ornithologie
à votre fils et que votre fille aussi a
su a su comment dire en faire profit
c'est pas très joli comme l expression
mais dans son travail auprès des jeunes
d'ados en difficulté enfin voilà ça
c'est une grosse pression monfils il est
vraiment passionné autant que je l'étais
avec avec les moyens qu'on a maintenant
c'est à dire les moyens mis la main donc
par exemple sa passion le fait
d'enregistrer les d'enregistrer les
oiseaux avec un micro parabolique et
d'essayer comme ça de voir la diversité
des émissions sonores de change au cri
d' allah
me de creep contact des jeunes c'est un
truc qui mettait inaccessible à l'époque
c'était très compliqué avec le numérique
en fait maintenant il ya des sites
internet sur lesquels on dépose
collaboratif ces enregistrements et
c'est donc lui il a vraiment il s'est
engagé à fond et en fait ça ces tranches
mais de manière presque osmotique c'est
à dire qu'en fait c'est quelque chose
qu'il a absorbé malgré elle les oiseaux
qu'on voit tout autant qu'on entend tout
le temps est ce que l a acquis elle a
acquis le savoir sont la passion est là
et et du savoir alors on peut dire en
quelques mots parce que ça risque d'être
long malheureusement quelles sont les
principales facteurs qui font que les
oiseaux disparaissent alors c'est assez
simple finalement c'est pas très
compliqué les oiseaux souffrent de la
faim pourquoi les oiseaux souffrent de
la faim après tout et puis d'insectes
voilà exactement en fait il ya vu un
effondrement des populations d'insectes
alors à cela s'ajoute effectivement le
réchauffement climatique qui pénalise
les espèces qui sont en limite sud aire
de répartition chez nous et qui ont
tendance à remonter vers le nord mais
globalement enfin en tous les cas
principalement plutôt la fin j'ai causé
directement par l'effondrement des
populations d'insectes un look et une
grosse publication qui sont sortis ces
deux dernières années qui sait
absolument phénoménal et il faut savoir
qu'en fait même les oiseaux qui sont
fruges ever ou granivores c'est à dire
qu'ils se nourrissent de fruits de
graines au moment de l'élevage
le jeune dealer leur leurs ressources je
poussais des insectes c'est à dire qu'un
jeu alors au moins deux mois d'enfants
sachant qu'ils vont avoir moins à manger
où c'est qu'ils meurent de faim voici
une couille peut-être idiak la famille
de direct on ne va pas trouver des
oiseaux morts de faim au son compagnon
dans la vie
loup dans les banlieues non c'est pas du
tout ça c'est effectivement le succès de
la reproduction qui est plus faible
d'accord c'est à dire qu'on est là ou là
où le renouvellement des populations se
faisaient par exemple pour une espèce
avec quatre jeunes parents trois jeunes
c'est sûr je voulais demander
en fait il ne reste pas beaucoup de
temps donc que je vous interromps un
petit peu excusez moi si nous citoyens
lambda on a envie d'agir à part moins
pollué et arrêtez de mettre des
pesticides si tant est qu'on en mette
qu'est-ce qu'on peut nourrir les oiseaux
nous mettre des boules pour les autos
dans mon jardin même en été tout le
monde il faut pas le faire en été en été
c'est assez peu c'est assez peu utile
c'est presque inutile alors il ya des
courants un peu dogmatique qui disent ah
mais non seulement c'est inutile mais en
plus c'est dommageable pour les oiseaux
parce que ont fait chuter la compétition
la compétition la nature malheureusement
pour faire chuter aussi simplement que
ça c'est assez dormi du tout ça cela
permet un vrai plaisir c'est de les voir
ça c'est du coup on les aime et on s'y
attache
et je pense que cela peut être un cercle
vertueux je pense pas qu'ils meurent de
digestion découvrir maintenant et
s'émerveiller de celles observées après
les échos renaît donc en les nourrissant
ça nous permet de les voir parce que
vous en êtes là vous allez vous êtes
extrêmement sensible aux champs est là
quand on n'est pas d'appart il eu chance
à bon ses ravisseurs mais on ne sait pas
mais les couleurs la beauté des oiseaux
déjà c'est c'est juste et alors dernière
petite question
ces fameuses perruches verte perruchas
que l'écolier qui envahissent
les capitales européennes et qui
envahissent un peu tout qui sont des
prédateurs
vous en dites quoi non mais franchement
ça des projets vers d autres non en fait
à l'annoncé c'est une question qu'on
s'est posée parce que effectivement leur
chez nous c'est relativement plus
récente par exemple à amsterdam
oui à barcelone et donc on s'est posé la
question qu'est ce qu'il y avait comme
compétition induites pour les sites de
nidification pour les ressources
alimentaires avec d autres oiseaux et
finalement on n'a pas mesuré
c'est à dire que là on a fait une étude
assez précise allamand joueurs on a
nourri artificiellement et on demande
aux gens de retrouver un temps réel les
interactions croisera la mangeoire une
amende et c'est pour les autres oiseaux
c'est l'équivalent d'un pigeon donc
c'est pas c'est pas très différent d'un
pigeon et il ya la ressource
donc c'est des oiseaux qui sont
cavernicoles qui nichent dans les
cavités la maison chaque collier on
s'est posé la question de la compétition
entre espèces pour ses qualités c'est à
dire hier la sittelle torchepot il ya le
pigeon colombin il ya tout un tas d
espèces qui les gens c'est qu'ils
habitent et on n'a pas non plus trouvé
des faits a barcelone il a été constaté
un effet direct sur des chaussures
rouges qui occupent les ces cavités viré
manu militari par les perruches mais on
est là constaté cet ep chez nous
d'accord bon alors maintenant qu'est-ce
que vous nous conseillez pour je ne sais
pas pour pour faire quelque chose
d'utile pour ces oiseaux
alors moi ce que je conseille donc c'est
à partir de cet automne où commence le
nourrissage et on essaie de s'inscrire
dans un programme c'est extrêmement
bienveillant ses programmes parce qu'on
est aidé par les autres dans un
programme d'observation au moment du
confinement on a eu une recrudescence de
deux participants finalement parce que
les gens étaient en quelque sorte d
ouvrir et est donc ce que je conseille
c'est de participer par exemple au
programme oiseaux des jardins au
programme bird la caisse au programme
sur smartphone et en temps réel les
interactions la mangeoire et de
découvrir comme ça on commence avec peu
d'espèces on commence par apprendre ce
que c'est qu'un verdi est ce que c'est
qu'un chardonnerets et puis finalement
la fin on vous connaît tout
reconnaît diversité et on s'émerveille
de cette diversité et pourquoi est ce
que le camp beaufre eux c'est votre
petit chouchou comme à beaucoup
d'ornithologues j'ai l'impression le
corbeau freux en fait il a alors il ya
une sale réputation ou produit ses parts
approuvent l'aimé beaucoup
moi j'aime beaucoup c'est la contraction
de la fraude on peut le mal aimé
c'est un bleu cet oiseau jeune allemand
tonton on lui prête tous les maux alors
c'est vrai qu'il a il affectionne les
semis donc ils mangent les ce n'est pas
très sympa
les agriculteurs les par contre il a
cette vie collectifs un oiseau qui niche
grande en grand bastion collectif et il
a fait enfin moi j'ai découvert en
allant en écosse par hasard que
finalement là bas on pouvait l'approcher
à un ou deux mètres et cela n'est pas
entre gelabale au qu'il est chez nous
non c'est bon a donné j'ai envie j'ai
envie de vous poser trois tonnes de
questions mais c'est pas possible donc
on va lire ce livre déjà qui nous
apprend plein de choses qui nous ouvre
bien les yeux et puis on va se demander
aussi pourquoi on a encore le droit de
chasser des oiseaux à la glu pourquoi
ces gens n'ont pas d'enfant pour leur
dire arrêtez c'est dégueulasse
enfin ça c'est encore un problème
grégoire loïs merci où va profiter de
l'été pour observer les oiseaux les
nourrir et jouir de leurs champs et de
leur beauté
merci à très bientôt j'espère en voir
gregor
[Musique]